leider da morgen die weihnachtszeit
losgeht hatte ich ein kleines geschenk
für euch ist ok wat beiseite meine
lieben freunde ich darf euch heute
herzlich willkommen heißt eine neue
action von mir auf hilft mir baby deluxe
reich sein vortäuschen um jeden preis
vor wie reaction staaten schauen und
standesgemäß wieder einige kommentare an
die tochter sieht irgendwie aus als wäre
sie schon 80 hier gelesen drauf gedrückt
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
was für vorbildliche mutter trinken halt
auf dem spielplatz wäre ihre kinder
nebenher spielen die tochter sieht aus
wie die von donna dieses kind altar wir
wissen doch alle nicht warum wir hier
sind doch
bei gehirnzellen verstört werden die
alleinerziehende maike strebt trotz
ihres geringen einkommens ein leben im
luxus an das machen ja eigentlich
relativ viele also verwerflich ist es
jetzt nicht so hamm die neuerdings hier
animation oder neben ihrer fünfjährigen
tochter justiz
ok
justine könnt wirklich irgendwo zwischen
95 jahre alt sein ich weiß dass viele
leute aufregt allerdings liegt sie mir
einfach am herzen dass in jeder reaktion
zu sagen meine kommentare sind nämlich
zu 0,0 verletzend gemeint ich möchte
keine person beleidigen und es richtet
sich immer nur zu der geschauspielert
eine rolle und nicht gegen die person
hinter der person
was sinn ergibt ist erster sandra die
sachen zugs person im leben des 26
jährigen sandra ist auch die helden und
hatten 900 euro einkommen das sind 900
euro mehr als sandra spaniens system das
heißt es sich in sachen war nämlich fall
teuer
hauptsache louis bacon tasche mit hartz4
bruder dann hat mich an sandra mit ihrer
neuen gucci tasche ehrlich gesagt super
qualität und er kann es nicht überhaupt
nichts sagen vor dem wir angst und sie
bezahlst du das ja ihr habt da schon
noch zeit das zu bezahlen
ich habe schon noch zeit dazu wird sein
schöne grüße gehen raus meine schwester
einem pelzmantel im august hochgeladen
mensch da braucht man den pelzmantel da
wirklich das ist keine details nannte
er kommt noch mal 100 euro für uns nicht
erst mal eine rechnung bezahlen bevor
wir zweiter geld ausgibst
weil legt da auch schon so vielleicht
kaufe ich auch bereit zum preis von 4
3 zum preis von 4
niemand am spielplatz und peya so auch
keine wertung einfach mal
lebensmittelkauf stuff brauchen kind
keine play it brauchen page sattel und
besonders im sommer auf dem spielplatz
so kam es dass sie bei uns damals war
manni da wird zwar alleine in
irgendwelche tollen sachen gehabt und
sind braucht sowas unglücklich wenn du
ja doch das ist einfach richtig kinder
brauchen pelzmäntel ich mache jetzt
petition offen nervt mich doch nicht mit
solchen sachen jetzt das glück hältst
nicht einen pelzmantel und ob neben
seinen wagen heinz vereinigt euch doch
es versteht sich von selber dass ein
kind ein pelzmantel brauche ich verstehe
diese sandra ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so
fanatisch aber warum rede ich eigentlich
mit den leuten da immer mit als würden
die mir dann zurück hallo sagen oder
probieren ist im altenheim die aller
coolste mit sind immer noch 120
opernrollen exakte wahrscheinlich auch
noch wenn ich gerne noch den vergoldeten
drucker
das habe ich bin heute auch völlig los
der ist noch nicht gold luca ist kein
problem ich bin zehn euro rabatt
eingestehen das wundervoll möchte ihnen
manche gleich anfangen
klar ist doch sommer da braucht man
sollte kann ich auch wenn mit den leuten
doch bitte zu reden
aber ich habe mir selber geredet ich hab
schon wieder mit mir selber ich hatte
die ganze zeit mit mir selber
unzufrieden ist jetzt eigentlich dein
ernst gewesen gerade warum wir wollten
lebensmittel einkaufen gehen hab mir
braucht den lebensmittel wendt und
pelzmantel haben kann sandra bisschen
was könntest du ja auch noch zu stecken
so etwas zu steht nur 200 euro von
pelzmantel ausgegeben das versteht sich
von selber aber schick dieser neuen
nicht den wert eines pelzmantel
du mich nicht ist wichtig eine familie
eine hand wäscht die andere versteht
sich von selbst gibt auch sowie der
pelzmantel im sommer der muss einfach
sein soll wieder die lücke wirklich mit
ihnen da schon aus mit jetzt ganz viel
geld er schreit mich doch nicht so auf
weil da kommt der sonne birgit von der
seite reingeschlittert oder wart ja es
war ja wieder so klar dass so ein
schwachsinn in köln gedreht werden auf
unsere spielplätze ich überhaupt nicht
gerne mit system
ich war dann gern mit ihr ins
villenviertel vor das dementsprechende
klientel ist und sie einfach auf das
bessere umfeld zum spielen hat so
versteht sich von selber
das ist allerdings nicht das kölner
villenviertel hier sondern das ist
direkt neben dem industriegebiet
da wo meine wilden steht in köln ist das
definitiv nicht
hallo zu machen so
es ist auch richtig der spielplatz wird
er ist wahnsinn was die kinder dafür
eine spielplatz
ihr wisst was ich meine mein kind hat
immer noch mit goldbarren in pelzmänteln
gespielt
im sommer
damit hätte
in monaco
vorgenommen und auf
20 euro also ich hatte ein paar gläser
oder die kinder schildert plastik gläser
kommst du clara wieder
maike plastik leder direkt einen
billigen namen vergessen so das tut mir
total leid mein mann zahlt die
eigentlich so viel geld aber man muss
wahrscheinlich die plastik leser aus
passieren und es auch gold plastik das
muss man auch mal dazu sagen dass aus
diamanten und rubinen gemacht
gold plastik aus diamanten samawi los
bin ich heute anstatt der richtigen
eigen der kristallgläser eingepackt das
geil ich kann das einfach nicht sein
weil die maschinen mein mann ist ja
ständig unterwegs
in new york ist eine kleine notlüge
es heißt auch nicht weiter schlimm so
versteht sich von selber das ist
überhaupt nicht schlimm hatte hat jetzt
eigentlich im pelzmantel auch auf dem
spielplatz an
denn da hat sie dem pelzmantel risse
auch in prosecco haben das wundervoll
die traumhaft erst klasse maike der kind
schon sehr gestalt für das alter wobei
ich habe zweifel dass es sich in den
klamotten war dreckig machen darf
natürlich dafür pelzmäntel noch da
ich glaube ich sollte das video ganz
schnell wenden sonst möglich dennoch im
quadrat und daher meine lieben freunde
wenn euch meine reaktion hierauf hilf
mir baby deluxe gefallen hat dass sie
gerne einen daumen hoch unter video da
schreibt in die kommentare ob ich die
tage auf platz zwei davon reagieren soll
bzw mir erst mal das video zu ende
schauen sollte wir sind mir zur hälfte
gekommen mit meinen ganzen dummen
kommentaren
[Musik]